[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous je m'appelle et m'a alors
je sais pas comment ça se passe pour
vous quand vous rencontrez des nouvelles
personnes chez des amis un dîner un
mariage et qu'on vous pose cette fameuse
question et toi tu fais quoi dans la vie
personnellement si j'y réponds je sais
que j'ai le droit à peu près à une heure
d'interrogatoire juste le temps que les
petits fours refroidissent
général manger de réaction c'est vrai
non mais attends le truc de dingue tu
sais que j'ai toujours rêvé de faire ce
métier tu as déjà rencontré un serial
killer ou l' inverse c'est pas vrai a
non je sais pas comment tu fais je
n'aurais jamais pu faire ça tu as dû
voir des trucs horribles vas-y raconte
en un mot psychocriminologue ça fascine
quant à savoir pourquoi et comment je
fais ce métier c'est ce que je m'apprête
à vous raconter
alors on a tous tenté ici de résoudre
une enquête criminelle au moins une fois
dans sa vie si on a tous joué au cluedo
mademoiselle rose qui tue le colonel
moutarde avec un chandelier dans la
véranda ça vous dit forcément quelque
chose c'est pas commun comme cremins
généralement on s'en souvient alors à la
fin du jeu peut-on considérer qu'on a
résolues l'anc est oui
peut-on dire qu'on a fait éclater la
vérité non on à l'arme du crime on a le
lieu du crime on a le corps de la
victime
on a des suspects quarté gagnant c'est
quand même assez rare et après une
enquête de longue haleine qui va
consister à piocher les cartes chez son
voisin on va enfin avoir notre coupable
mademoiselle rose mais
connaîtront ses motivations quand je
veux dire il faut quand même être
sacrément être en colère pour faire
s'écraser un chandelier sur la tête d'un
colonel moi je pense qu'il est vraiment
temps de rajouter les cartes mobiles
dans le cluedo on pourrait par exemple
avoir la légitime défense l'héritage la
séparation l'adultère parce que c'est
précisément le mode il qui va venir
donner du sens au passage à l'acte et
qui va souvent constituer la clé de
l'enquète le comment c'est ce qui est
observable constat c'est la réalité
brute des faits le pourquoi lui il est
bien plus difficile à cerner j'ai pu
constater pendant mes 15 ans pratiquent
que le lieu n'est jamais anodin que la
victime ne l'est jamais par hasard ça ne
veut pas dire qu'elle connaît toujours
son auteur ça peut être une victime
d'opportunités mais dans ce cas elle va
rentrer dans une logique qu'elle ignore
celle de l'auteur et que l' arme du
crime tout comme le mode opératoire ne
sont jamais le fruit du hasard
donc comprendre un passage à l'acte
l'analyse est rentré dans la tête du
tueur que même bien le dire les médias
c'est là qu'une grande partie de la
vérité va se cacher
et quand une affaire piétine cette quête
de sens devient primordial laisser notre
rôle nous psychocriminologue
de dresser des profils de donner des
priorités aux axes banquette mais
surtout d'aider les enquêteurs à
remettre du sens sur l'impensable
alors mettons mademoiselle rose de côté
et prenons l'exemple d'une affaire sur
laquelle j'ai travaillé et que l'office
central de la répression des violences
aux personnes l'ocr vp pour les intimes
a résolu trente ans après
on est en été
un jeune homme d'une vingtaine d'années
est retrouvé mort dans un bois poignardé
de plusieurs coups de couteau il n'y a
aucune marque de défense sa chemise est
ouverte elle n'est pas perforé il est en
caleçon et son chant se trouve un petit
peu plus loin
la dernière personne à l'avoir vue c'est
son meilleur ami qui dit qu'il a déposée
à une fête foraine vers 23 heures avant
de repartir les deux amis devaient
partir tous deux en vacances pendant
quinze jours le lendemain les policiers
de l'époque vont balayer toute sa vie
professionnelle personnelle familiale
amicale ils vont suivre différentes
pistes des très sérieuses comme des plus
farfelus pour autant l'enquète va
s'enliser
des années plus tard le servait paix va
être saisi du dossier et notre chef de
service va nous demander de dresser ce
qu'on pourrait appeler
une autopsie du passage à l'acte
alors pour cela on se sert de la
procédure il faut visualiser
ici des dizaines et des dizaines de
milliers de pages fait de rapports de
police ont toujours des constatations
l'autopsié des rapports de police
technique et scientifique des enquêtes
de voisinage des auditions des
témoignages et cette procédure on va pas
la lire une fois mais deux trois quatre
fois parce que ce qui n'a pas
d'importance à la première lecture peut
en avoir beaucoup à la dernière on a
besoin d'une vision globale
d'ensemble pour avoir une vision plus
détaillée
alors concrètement et synthétiquement
que nous dit ce crime reprenons la
triade lieu victime hauteur
au niveau du lieu on sait que c'est une
partie de la forêt dans laquelle se se
pratique des relations homosexuelles
tarifée ou non dont il n'y a pas que de
la prostitution le souci c'est que la
famille de la victime tout comme ses
amis déclare certain avec certitude que
l'afld que la victime n'est pas
homosexuel alors là je fais une petite
parenthèse autant la vérité juridique se
doit d'être unique lors du procès autant
celles des protagonistes qui la
composent et souvent multiples alors
j'entends par protagonistes la famille
les témoins les amis l'auteur lui même
et la victime s'est elle encore en vie
on a tous une vision de soi des autres
de ce qu'on vit de ce qu'on ressent qui
est différente qui est nuancée on ne
peut donc pas écarté la possibilité que
la victime soit homosexuel à la pub
cacher et n'oublions pas le lieu dans
lequel allait retrouver et la façon dont
elle était vêtue évidemment mise à part
ça cette victime n'y a pas grand chose
sur elle c'est un jeune homme issu de
bonne famille il n'y a pas de problème
d'argent il n'a pas de problème d'alcool
là pas de problème de drogue n'a pas
d'aix en colère
son entourage s'accordent à dire que
c'est quelqu'un de plutôt sympathique
enjouée qui n'est pas du tout
conflictuelle qui n'est pas bagarreur et
certains peuvent dire qu'il est un brin
hautain pas grand chose en fait
heureusement la scène de crime a plus
d'informations à nous donner
au niveau de larmes elle n'est pas
retrouvée sur les lieux mail autopsie va
permettre d'en dresser ses grandes
caractéristiques on sait que ce n'est
pas un opinel ce genre de petit couteau
qu'on pourrait avoir dans sa poche là on
a affaire à un vrai couteau de cuisine
avec une lame de plus de dix centimètres
je sais pas si vous visualisez ce crime
on peut donc partir du principe que
l'auteur l'a pas trouvée sur les lieux
c'est pas une arme d'opportunités et
qu'il est venu avec
alors l'intention de tuer n'est pas
forcément là dès le départ ça peut être
l'intimidation ou la menace
sauf que souvenez vous la victime est
attaqué deux faces et qu'il n'y a aucune
marque de défense qu'est ce que ça veut
dire
ça veut dire que cette victime elle se
sent en confiance avec son agresseur on
peut donc imaginer que c'est un
agresseur de proximité que la victime
connaît depuis plus ou moins longtemps
en tout cas elle a suffisamment
confiance pour être avec lui en pleine
nuit dans une forêt
au niveau de la scène de crime
elle nous donne souvent des indications
sur l'état émotionnel de l'auteur au
moment du passage à l'acte
là on a une dizaine de coups de couteau
finalement c'est pas assez pour une
simple exécution métro pour qualifier le
crime de ce qu'on pourrait dire un crime
passionnel la rage meurtrière qui sont
souvent gouverné par des émotions
beaucoup plus fortes comme l'amour la
haine et aussi la folie là on est dans
quelque chose de beaucoup plus mesurée
néanmoins la majorité des coups de
couteau ont lieu sur des zones létale ça
veut dire qu'on ne peut pas ignorer
l'intention de détruire et de tuer la
victime
de façon générale que nous dit la psycho
criminologie sur le passage à l'acte on
sait qu'il est toujours singulier c'est
le dire quoi ça veut dire qu'on ne peut
pas le comparer à aucun autre crime la
raison est simple la victime elle est
unique potter il est unique et leur
rencontre dans un moment donné et dans
un endroit donné est elle aussi unique
la deuxième chose que l'on sait sur le
passage à l'acte c'est qu'il est
toujours multifactorielles ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que ça va être un
ensemble de facteurs qui vont amener un
individu un moment donné à passer à
l'acte très souvent il ya un déclencheur
qui a lieu de quelques minutes à
quelques années avant le crime mais
celui ci est très difficilement
identifiables et quand on y arrive c'est
souvent grâce aux aveux la dernière
chose et c'est certainement la plus
importante
le passage à l'acte est un processus
dynamique qui va consister en une
transformation de la passivité à
l'activité ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que le passage à l'acte est
toujours toujours la résolution d'un
conflit le moyen pour l'auteur de
reprendre le contrôle la maîtrise le
pouvoir sur sa vie
alors une fois qu'on sait ça on va
reprendre la liste des suspects de
l'époque il y en a un qui va attirer
notre attention le fameux meilleur ami
déjà c'est la dernière personne à avoir
vu la victime c'est généralement pas une
place très confortable la deuxième chose
c'est que son emploi du temps et pas
très claires il dit avoir déposé la
victime vers 23 heures puis être allée
dormir chez sa copine qui n'est pas là
elle est en vacances elle ne peut pas
confirmer et puis ne trouvant pas le
sommeil et les ressortir est allé se
balader dans un parent qui sait pas trop
combien de temps et puis les revenues
qui au petit matin et la laver sa
voiture bref c'est confus une autre
chose intéressante c'est que sa petite
amie qui est en vacances
lorsqu'elle sera auditionné va nous dire
que son chéri est plutôt impulsif
et puis que ça leur arrive de se
disputer ça assez conflictuelles entre
eux et qu'ils en sont même venus une
fois se menacer tous deux d'un couteau
évidemment cette information elle est
intéressante elle nous permet surtout
nous de mesurer le degré de violence
potentielle de l'individu la violence
est plutôt la tente mais on sait qu'elle
peut être explosive et finalement à sa
colle plutôt bien à ce passage à l'acte
le problème c'est qu'il n'ya aucune
trace d'un conflit intérieur ou
interpersonnelles avec la victime tout
le monde s'accorde à dire qu'il
s'entendait très bien qu'ils se
connaissaient depuis longtemps et qu'ils
étaient heureux de partir en vacances
le lendemain
alors on va le chercher ce conflit
intérieur on va essayer d'analyser un
petit peu ces auditions et puis ces
précautions verbale ou non il ya quelque
chose qui va se détacher c'est un
complexe d'infériorité qu'il a vis-à-vis
de la victime strel attend et puis on
voit que c'est un fait d'une émotion au
début on croit que c'est de la jalousie
et puis finalement on voit plutôt de la
rancoeur il ya des termes d obligeant
qui sont là mais cette rancoeur on ne
s'explique pas on n'a pas toutes les
informations
néanmoins on va le mettre en tête de
liste de nos suspect très peu de temps
après il ya un nouveau témoignage qui va
relancer l' enquête et qui va convaincre
finir de convaincre le juge est notre
chef de service d'aller arrêter ce
fameux meilleur ami des années plus tard
le souci c'est que sur les 48 heures de
garde à vue il en reste plus que six ça
fait quand même très peu pour faire
parler quelqu'un et c'est là que mon
deuxième rôle en tant que psycho
criminologue rentrer en action
nous sommes censés aider les enquêteurs
à monter des stratégies d'auditions en
fonction de la personnalité potentiel de
l'auteur et de ce qu'il a commis qu'on
s'entende bien le psycho criminologue
n'est pas là pour mener l'audition il
observe ville analyses et conseils quand
il le peut
généralement on a deux angles d'attaqué
en audition l'intellect et l'affect
l'intellect il est plutôt utilisé pour
tout ce qui est crimes d'argent
criminalité organisée et une grosse
partie des tueur en série la raison elle
est simple c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'interaction en tout cas affective
entre l'auteur et la victime
la victime allait objecta lisez elle
n'est qu'un moyen pour l'auteur
d'accéder à son objectif donc avec eux
on va plutôt jouer sur la
rationalisation des preuves on va parler
de la qualité et de la quantité des
preuves on va argumenter on va
convaincre l'auteur al'inverse quand on
est dans l'affect comme dans ce crime on
va plutôt amener de l'empathie on va
appuyer sur la culpabilité qui
gangrènent l'individu de semaines de
mois ou d'années comme celui ci
on va amener l'auteur à libérer sa
conscience
vaste programme
quelle que soit la stratégie d'audition
il ne faut jamais oublier que avoué est
toujours précédée d'une prise de
décision on n'avoue pas par hasard on
décide d'avouer on est donc là pour
amener l'auteur à se dire que c'est pour
lui la meilleure des solutions
donc il ya une règle d'or en audition
c'est le silence
il faut savoir écouter il faut savoir
laisser parler et il faut donner le
temps de réfléchir
tous les abus auxquels j'ai pu assister
ont toujours eu lieu après une pause
pause déjeuner possible arrête
et surtout longue pause celle de la nuit
c'est l'heure on est seul avec soi-même
qu'on peut on pèse le pour et le contre
ce jeune homme de 23 ans qui en a
maintenant 51 n'a pas dérogé à la règle
il avoué en quelques heures au début de
sa deuxième audition
soulagé nous dira-t-il de dire enfin la
vérité alors quelle était cette vérité
quel était ce conflit je suis sympa j'ai
pris une affaire résolue
alors ce meilleure amie va nous dire
qu'il était sous emprise sous la
domination de son ami une domination qui
se jouait sur beaucoup de tableaux mais
un qu'il était devenu insupportable pour
lui
la victime l'incitait jeudi un site est
pas forcé son ami à lui pratiquer des
fellations et de la masturbation lui
n'en avait pas envie mais ne savait pas
comment refuser au fil du temps il s'est
senti acculé
lorsqu'ils ont prévu leurs vacances
ensemble
c'était devenu pour lui insupportable
il est donc allé acheter un couteau au
cas où
quand la veille la victime lui propose
de 2 voire pour préparer leur voyage il
accepte quand la victime me propose
d'aller dans cette forêt qu'il connaît
bien pour y être déjà allés avec lui il
y va il prend son couteau qu'il cache
évidemment au cas où quand la victime
lui propose
de le masturber il accepte il s'exécute
une fois qu'il aura fini va le
poignarder à mort il aura enfin repris
le contrôle sur sa vie
donc finalement ce vieil adage
qu'on entend à qui profite le crime est
assez limité oui il peut y avoir une
quête de vengeance de sexe d'argent mais
quel que soit le mobile tous répondent
toujours à cette même logique implacable
qui est de reprendre le contrôle
reprendre la maîtrise sur sa vie et
apaiser ces tensions c'est à dire qu'à
un moment donné il ya une situation une
personne une émotion une frustration qui
vont venir déséquilibrer un individu et
sa seule façon de répondre à cela ça va
être de passer à l'acte
remettre du sens dans ce passage à
l'acte
ça peut aider à obtenir des aveux ça
peut parfois résoudre une enquête
mais ça va surtout permettre de
pratiquer une justice juste
comprendre ce n'est pas excuser ce n'est
pas donner des circonstances atténuantes
c'est se souvenir que c'est un axe à
part dont un acte extraordinaire souvent
chez des personnes très ordinaire
alors ma conclusion serait que pour moi
on a vraiment résolu une enquête pas
quand on sait qu'en ce comment ça s'est
passé mais surtout quand on comprend
pourquoi ça a eu lieu alors je me pose
toujours et encore cette même question
pourquoi mademoiselle rose at elle tué
le colonel moutarde
merci
[Applaudissements]